and there we go so good evening again
and welcome to creative thought i'm so
happy to see all the crowd here uh thank
you so much to the organizers of pi data
because it is a great pleasure to have
the event organized here at creativedoc
my name is adam hunka and i work as a
data scientist here in a big data team
and you know creative talk is all about
innovations and we do innovations in
many different areas and tonight i'll be
talking about innovations or as i change
the name of the digital transformation
in insurance and banking
so first of all let me do a quick survey
how many of you like your bank who is
excited about your bank or the services
can you raise your hands
okay
that's good quite a few people
kind of expected that
what about your insurance company
not so many okay but still someone yes
good thank you
kinda expected right so if we talk about
innovations it is first of all important
to say why we do them and
honestly this has been a struggle to me
since i joined creative though it was
always yeah we're doing innovations but
um come on it's been working somehow
right so why do they need to do
innovations and then i had a look at
a way that
population is structured okay boomers
they're really happy right they got
their services then it's the genics
my parents basically they're also pretty
happy with the services and then it's
coming it's me as a millennial
and the next one is a gen z another
thinking okay so what kind of insurance
we might be selling let's say it will be
a life insurance are you selling life
insurance to boomers no not anymore they
either have it or they don't need it
anymore um so
the crowd that you're actually offering
these projects to is millennials and
generation z
the market has changed because the time
are changing
heard at some place right
so if we just go into comparing the two
generations and you might notice that in
my talk i might not even mention the
word python because i kind of believe
that we need to talk about concepts
first before we go into implementing
them
well so why do we actually do these
innovations um generation z or
millennials even the generation z are
not using facebook this might come
across as a bit of a surprise to people
who grew up with
the platform like myself but when i
heard about marketing data they told me
well um you know you do marketing for
someone who is 22 23 24 you have to use
instagram because dear facebook
attendance is extraordinary it's like
why is that well the sweet secret is
that each generation has their own
social media platform because that's the
one where you don't have your parents on
it
so
you know you get used to a different
paradigm of working of existence
in the world
they use different devices
for example millennials they will be
using desktops i'm one of them i love my
computer and i'm always pretty desperate
when i have to work with a phone device
because you know my fingers are just so
big and i wasn't i wasn't really
born with a thumb in the way that fits
the smartphone don't know how you feel
about that but it actually hurts i mean
after some time that i use the
smartphone my thumb starts hurting the
new generation didn't have that because
they grew up the way
usage of tv usage of laptops everything
changes
and then okay marketing people would say
okay they have
least attention span of eight seconds
it's not true the truth is that the gen
z and the people whom we're building the
products in the next five ten years for
they have a very sophisticated filter
because they grew up in a world where a
lot of information is meshing on them so
if you're able to keep their attention
if you're able to create a product so
that they really like it they will read
it you will have their focus but you
have to think about it first
so
psychology gets into game
and when i think about how the media
actually work with me then i always
think okay this is a great example
because
you might know these carousels on
facebook
what does it say i show you half of the
image
just half of the image because you want
to see more
i am trying to get your attention you
press the button
it shows you the full image and then the
half of the next one and this is exactly
the paradigm that many companies have
been able to adopt
but many haven't and one of them might
be the insurance or the banking system
let's go to a bit more examples so which
series do you guys grow up with i was
mine
i was airing when i was 15 i see some
people nodding yes so it's much more
about community it's much more about
living together and it's much less about
actually being successful in life if you
go a couple of slides back you will see
that the generation z has exactly these
targets millennials yes we are ambitious
but the gen z might not be as ambitious
they might want to
be special every one of them is special
right they have been taught that
and if you think about psychology again
and now compare these services to your
favorite insurance company
you hungry
at midnight
get your pizza have it at home
with your friends
don't go into an expensive restaurant
have it delivered
you want to go someplace yeah taxi taxi
drivers a really bad reputation
really bad reputation means that you
want to replace the service you are not
providing a different service then if
you go by taxi you're providing a
different feeling
again spotify
perfect moment play the perfect song
you exactly
choose what you want to have so enough
for the marketing theory now how do we
do these innovations
sit in a corner sometimes someone comes
and asks like can you actually do this
or i have an idea how do you approach
that so my answer always is if you can
throw it on whiteboard then i can
explain it to the computer
and this is actually the paradigm that i
think innovations live with we really
have to think
about what kind of areas we want to
innovate before we start smashing it
into neural networks
because everyone talks about machine
learning
but no one really talks about what we
use it for
um i've put together a couple of
different areas in which uh we have done
innovations and i will show you step by
step
how these innovations can be built up
and of course just to say python prime
is running beneath both of them
we can talk about customer experience
i'll go a bit deeper into this model
later because i also have a case study
of how to really implement one of the
one of the things that i'm presenting
but if you think about customer
experience
so you crash your car
right what do you do now call your
insurance company fill in the form oh my
gosh there is a car flying in a space on
a spacex or still calling your insurance
company
do you like it no you want to do it with
your phone
so
just take pictures
there is a neural network behind it that
actually does the evaluation it's got
the automation of the liquidation
process it shows you which parts of the
car have been damaged and it also shows
you the estimated cost
and then the company says okay we have
some kind of a anti-fraud and it pays
the bill works well
so first real innovation
i know you're removing manual work which
means that you will have to restructure
the market but that's what innovations
are about you give people more time
um
now there is a lot of human work
involved with the crash app um
just a prototype yet
you have an expert system what it is
about customer experience customers want
to have simple experience you call uber
you don't go buy a taxi
what about car insurance by themselves
so
um
when you hear about insurance people
very often say okay i've been paying for
a long time i don't get so much back how
is it possible well that's how insurance
works but still some kind of innovation
is possible in this area because you
talk about people human feelings and
feelings are important face it
um so what if you just give someone 30
back if they drive well
there's a lot of data science involved
and now if we do a brainstorming i'll
bring a whiteboard you will come up with
most of the ideas behind this app within
30 minutes i promised that
you need to cut curves okay to warping
it's in library
maybe you will treat the parameters
but what is really important is
to say there is a concept of
personalization that the python and the
data science that we all know has to be
applied to
um
yeah that's basically
what i summarized before a lot of data
floating in the app you have to have
anti-fraud checks you have to have
checks of speeding you have to be able
to evaluate the customer's behavior
because if they behave well on the
street
you give them a cash back
that's also a public service thing
so you motivate people to drive
carefully
you're bringing back to the society you
don't even know it
um
you can measure their acceleration
how do you do that
with a phone it's got all the sensorics
you need
you cannot use gyroscope and all the
stuff that is in your iphone for
measuring a distance because it's got a
squared error
but you can you can use it for measuring
other the
values that give you a certain idea
about how the person is or is not
speeding
data science included yes do you need
people to label your data yes of course
but still
it's mainly about personalization about
giving the user the feeling that they
are involved in their own insurance cost
not not just okay how many of you
insured your car
on the name of your parents because
they've been driving for 20 years and
never had an accident okay don't raise
your hands i know yeah but i know a lot
of people who did that why because
that's the only personalization that you
currently have in the car insurance just
hey daddy you haven't had an accident
for 20 years so can you please reduce my
cost of the insurance no now you can do
it yourself
and then a third example which features
personalization and simplicity is the
insurance mutumudu it is life insurance
and again it solves couple of different
issues that people have with life
insurance for example
premiums back if you have a healthy life
what is it personalization what is it
your own individual responsibility for
how much you're paying you get a lot of
bonuses if you live healthy
not so good for smokers though um it is
simple right if you
have a insurance life insurance that
very often you would be like yeah does
it really hold for this and that
situation there are a couple of
exemptions but only eight
if you have a look at other life
insurances you'll be counting much more
than that so simplicity is also very
important you have a simple website you
can apply to that now again what kind of
data do you need um cell phone
great
google health
great you have it so make interfaces
um if you do some running if you do
exercises they also give you a watch so
that you can measure it
in a gym that's the innovation behind it
so think about the user go towards the
user if you do regular medical checkups
again you get bonuses
no python included in these ideas and
all of you know how to implement it if
you think for 25 minutes and have a beer
now um i know that there are a couple of
technical people i've heard
so i also wanted to give you a bit of a
case study on how we implemented the
crash device the crash app
crash means
well
my aim is to identify if a car is broken
how much it is broken and if it can be
repaid or not
now
you see this image and you say well
there is a neural network behind it
right so yeah pretty much
is it damaged is it no damage is it
surface damaged is it just scratched
it's labeling
but okay let's get into it so first of
all
um maybe at this point i should go back
to the audience do you guys have any
questions so far
oh
okay
then um
afterwards maybe
yep go ahead go ahead
you have to submit the images of the car
when you when you conclude the insurance
so you will always have a checkup at the
beginning what kind of car you're
actually insuring in the insurance so if
it is crashed in the beginning
sorry but it will be visible
thanks for the question though uh the
same way kubrick was there was um
insurance for small devices you could
insure a couple of devices you would
first have to take pictures of the
devices
um the biggest trouble there how do you
take a picture of your phone by the way
sorry to the guys from cubic
any other questions
good
so first of all
you do a labeling and classification and
detection of car parts
easy-peasy you see the lights you see
the wheels you see the front part
um
how you do it you get images
not so difficult
google a car google crash car you find a
lot of images online there are also data
sets that you can use for it or if you
have a client that you're cooperating
with of course they're going to provide
you with a lot of data that i have
collected over the past couple of years
what is also important knowing the post
of the car so first of all you trade a
small classifier that gives you the post
of the car i'll get to this a bit later
but you see there is nothing not nothing
really difficult with it so that's why
i'm arguing that data science nowadays
is more about the concepts and ideas
than about really using the right
algorithm because all of them somehow
work in the same way
um
you do some future learning
how many times have you seen a image of
a neural network like this
have you ever seen a different one
though
no this is a cnn simple cnn
[Music]
so first you search for
car parts of unbroken cars
and then oh what is really important
manual labeling for menu labeling you
can use services that are out there
um simply speaking you send the pictures
to intel or
you find someone who will do it in your
company depends on how you want to
approach your data depends also
on how much your data is generic that
you can use it or
if you need some kind of a very specific
knowledge of the data right because the
more specific data you have the more
inside of the company you have to work
with them
[Music]
rcman
regional convolutional neural networks
you can find them in tensorflow and they
give you a boost they give you speed up
and a very high precision of the car
parts more than 95 precision of
recognition of the car parts and then
the evaluation of broken and non-broken
car parts
so you have to say okay this is a wheel
and it's not broken
it's basically about how many images
you're able to collect for the neural
network and how much precision can be
raised in your algorithm
um just to go through the model
first of all you need to decide the
viewpoint of the car because it will be
different from the back and different
from the front so this is the first
classifier that you put on the way
then
you use the regional convolutional
neural networks that you feed with you
don't need that many images by the way
so if you go with
a thousand two thousand you can already
achieve good results if you want to have
more precision of course pair up with a
company and this company will probably
provide you with more images and then
they will they might also have labels if
not labels are the crucial part of the
whole process and they're the most
they're most difficult to obtain i see
and raised
[Music]
you need to have more specific images of
the broken cars
so um car that is not broken is not so
difficult to learn but car that is
broken because there are different or
variety of damages um these images need
to be more frequent in the data set if
you want to be more secure with the
broken parts of the images
thanks for the question
um
yeah and like i was saying then if you
use data from an insurance company then
um
they would have usually around 20 images
per a in short event
10 will be from the inside 10 will be
from the outside
um
and um with this network um you can also
use um
mechanical turk so that's uh that's a
service that provides you with labeling
if you have data that is well
understandable if distributed across the
world
and um yeah so and
the final model was trained with
approximately 80 000 images 20 images
per a in short event and every
annotation counts for the whole insured
event
so you have to do aggregation
aggregation is easy take the average
is this clear
um
so how it works it is able to detect
broken car parts or damaged car parks
car parts not only after an accident but
also
yeah like you see if they're rusty
that's pretty much all for my talk
and now i'm open today questions thank
you guys
[Applause]
you